guys I've got a plethora of costumes and
friends to me tell me who you are what
you're doing here at pow well I'm
two-faced you fancy your chances yeah
I'm I'm the Joker trying to find Batman
and can't find him anywhere
I'm Superman just flew in to make sure
nothing nothing went down here seen as
though so many villains around I'm
Harley Quinn and I'm here to cause some
mischief and mayhem and poison ivy
number sake of a suitable and as you can
see his eyes were red so that you can
fight Batman for me so guys have you
been to lots of conventions before and
what's your experience here at Kapow
well this is actually our first one and
it's a great opportunity to meet the
artists and the rioters of you know
behind the comics and everything and
we're having a really good time do you
all know each other before you came to
power today you two guys do how do you
know each other boyfriend and girlfriend
this is kind of like good place to go
meet new people but a couple here you
know each other obviously already so
tell me a little bit about what you've
seen here at Kapow today what's
impressed you you tell me I met Terry
Dobson so I'm quite excited and got a
sketch of them that Jonathan Ross which
I got bit excited as well but yeah this
is really good for a man with like
here's a line to raise money for charity
as well so that's always a good thing to
come and do so you're doing a bit of
good as well as having fun doing it
and there's about so many people like
the charity have a website or anything I
think it just search he really likes UK
and he'll come with our website well
scour Facebook so if you ever want
interesting NSO events and stuff as well
use contact us do that and what about
you what have you been enjoying as they
as the villainous and superhero couple
well I'm enjoyed seeing everybody how
much they put into the effort into the
costumes and sort it's just fantastic
done for me it's definitely seeing the
artists and appreciating all the
original artwork that's here I come from
like a fine art background myself so I
do a lot of comic work and it's just
fantastic seeing all the other artists
around fantastic now how much time does
it take to kind of come up with these
costumes how about you Joker how long
did this ensemble take to put together
well I didn't take that long to rehearse
there but the joke yeah it took me about
two hours yeah we're the latex on it's
something that you've done before you
practice do a lot because it's you know
looking good yeah I've just done it once
before in the science fiction parade for
film week yeah
and so you're looking forward because
you've got the cosplay contest on on to
Thursday haven't they on the stage
you're looking forward to seeing what
the competitions like and how do you
think your chances are brilliant okay I
don't know it's tough competition
there's been some fantastic they have
costumes around I mean for example thing
over there just amazing yeah I think I
think he's got a very good chance of
winning this now if you could be any
other superhero or villain than the
person who come out today who would it
be your other ideal costume we start
with you to be Stephanie Brown either
spoiler or Robin version just so I think
she's really underrated and she's got a
lot of faces and sassiness is really
like without being overly underdressed
or anything like that
I bet you poison ivy when what not the
traditional Albert I'd like to make my
own and put my own kind of technique on
it this is something you put together
yourself as well how long did that take
I've been doing it for the past four
months about to stitch on every piece of
ivy and stitch all these on and
everything you a bit of us so a bit of a
costume maker anyway I love sewing and
stuff but it's like my boots as well up
stuck older you know you got to proper
lot of effort haven't you all of you
with these definitely how about you
Superman who else would you be
I'd love to come as venom my best
friend's comes carnage today so I kind
of I'd like to I'd like to do that next
time
that's very interesting I have at you
Joker pretty big the Riddler yeah as the
other enemy how about you yeah I'm going
to try and do the penguin yeah bit of a
challenge so you guys you're all up for
coming next year it's give another
character power yeah excellent we look
forward to seeing you what you like next
year maybe some of the names you've
mentioned today and good luck with the
cosplay contest later
you